Yeah,
standup comedy is definitely harder.
I mean,
I like being on stage.
That's always been fun for me.
I'm better than A.
It's like people ask like,
how do you go up on stage?
I don't,
I don't think I could ever do it.
And my answer is like,
well,
I'm having trouble talking to you right
now.
It's like it's,
it's for some reason some people just
have it in their genetic makeup that
it's easier to go up and interact with a
group of strangers than it is to have
any kind of meaningful interaction with,
with a,
with a person whose eyes you have to
look into.
Um,
and I'm not saying that I'm a cold,
heartless monster,
but a little sick but still stand ups
harder because it's just you on your
own.
The great thing about the onion is it's
so collaborative,
you know,
it's almost kind of take on this group
mind there.
Um,
and people are really willing to
sacrifice their own personal pet
headlines,
um,
or their own preference on a joke for
the,
for the good of the,
of,
of the onion,
for the good of the product.
Um,
I don't think either that they,
that stand up informs my work at the
onion very much or vice versa,
um,
because they're pretty different in
style of the standup,
tends to be a little more,
um,
of a,
a
little more,
um,
kind of do this kind of character who
that exaggerates all of my own
nervousness and neuroses and they tend
to be a little more conceptual,
like as a,
as a eight minute set,
then telling a joke and then telling an
unrelated joke and then telling an
unrelated joke,
I can't,
uh,
I sort of can't write jokes that way
personally.
I have to think about how do I want
this,
this eight minutes to feel so that it
says awkward for the audience as
possible while also being funny and then
sort of right to that as opposed to this
is a good joke that I will expand on and
then find a segue into something else
for me.
I just can't.
It's really hard for me to do that.
Um,
so one thing the onion has sort of
taught me though is how to actually like
write material and how to hit a joke as
hard as you possibly can,
relentlessly until near to the point of,
of being too much.
So having that sense of something that
I've,
I've really gotten from working at the
onion,
you know,
over four years,
but the two are actually pretty,
pretty unrelated,
you know,
I do have a,
um,
a website that I keep up as well.
It's called the Joe Randazzo
Association,
which is,
now that I'm saying it,
it's this sort of large heartless
corporation,
um,
and it's the kind of goings on at the
office,
you know,
messages from,
from the HR representative and schedule
of events for a seminar and what the
lunch menu is going to be and it's those
kinds of things.
Um,
so the writing for that has definitely
been influenced a lot by my time at the
onion,
just didn't,
how to,
how to really write a joke.
But it's my own personal stuff because
sometimes you just need to write your
own personal stuff as well.
It's fun,
but it's also,
you know,
horrible.
Anybody who has to,
well,
I don't know if anybody,
but when you have to sit down and write
something,
it's just the most dreadful feeling in
the world for me anyway,
you know?
Uh,
but it's also really fun.
It's just,
you,
you forget when you're having fun,
you forget how,
how dreadful it is and when you're in
the dreadful,
you forget how fun it can be,
you know,
uh,
and you have to write something in order
to be able to have material to perform.
And that's when the fun is.
Um,
so I guess I sort of actually force
myself to do it and I've listened to
other,
um,
there's this great podcast I listen to
called the creative screenwriting
magazine,
um,
where I'm Jeff Gold Smith is his name.
He's a senior editor at the magazine,
I think,
and he interviews different
screenwriters every week and he always
asks them if they,
uh,
what did they do?
Did they get writer's block and do they,
what do they do to get rid of it?
And every time I'm like,
Ha,
I always have writers,
but writers block is the default
position for me.
It's like such a struggle to get these
ideas out so they,
they don't want to come out,
even though they're in,
they're driving me crazy.
Um,
but it's also just an incredible,
incredible to be able to have a career
out of making people laugh and,
or a job anyway.
I don't know if it's gonna,
if it will be a career
where you sit around in a room and,
and,
and make people laugh and then put
together something that's so great that
I can be so proud of,
you know,
when you see people on the street
reading the onion,
it's a really,
it's a really wonderful feeling.
And I always want to tell them,
you know,
I'm looking at mass tenets.
That's me.
Uh,
I've worked there.
Um,
so I'd say it's got to be that the fun
outweighs the dreadfulness for sure.
Yeah.
But it's work,
you know,
it's work.